hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for five nights at
freddys part dos I actually played this
for the first time last week if you go
on dance cyber channel that cyber
Channel there's a video with him and I
where we play five nights at Freddy's
first time I ever took a look at the
game it was a creepy game but honestly I
thought it could've been a little
creepier that could have been a little
scarier I just want this trailer to
impress me the most animatronics freaked
me out
[ __ ] Trekkie cheese I swear they came
to life one day and those animatronics
did something to me that I just will
never forget they teabag me why they
designed the animatronics with balls
well if you're homeless then chances are
you've made a very poor career choice
Bob okay I got me a little bit I cannot
believe I just screamed at I was too
close to the laptop it was like I'm
really interested in what's going on
here and then just came out of nowhere
yeah I mean it looks like it's five
nights at Freddy's and just uh you know
they amped up the beer
they've amped up play no doors yeah I
know I'm down I love to play that with
dan dan [ __ ] freaks out whenever you
know that the thing happens dan is so
afraid of this game is such a [ __ ] you
know he's like he gets scared shitless
man and speaking of shitless I went to
dance to play this game and he went out
to do laundry so I said I'm gonna go to
the bathroom and Dan had left some [ __ ]
in there for me literal [ __ ] in the
toilet so if you know Dan cyber it is oh
I know what Dan Seibert [ __ ] looks like
but now five nights at Freddy's I mean
it's a cool concept its sinister it's
kind of clever because it's such a
simple [ __ ] game yet it's like you
want to keep playing for some reason
like you're you are hooked in it it's so
[ __ ] simple but you do like you do
get a kick out of it man and I [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know the boss or whoever
meetin the guy keeps calling in and
giving you advice like dude that guy is
just the I don't like him I don't like
him I think he's an ass I don't like him
dip my balls in his mouth at causing him
trauma not because not because I wanted
to I don't know he looks like he'd be
like the ugliest fast guy in the world
or he could be really good-looking who
knows anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where we do trailer reactions
splash reviews if you can call what I
just did a review you know have movie
reviews and their short films
there's just so much like a log up here
oh my god were a channel of variety so
if you guys want to shout out a lot of
people been asking in the comments and
the bigger the channel gets art is to
keep up but I put up a Facebook page
facebook.com slash the real rejects
shoutouts so if you want a shout out or
you haven't gotten one yet just go to
this Facebook page yeah joke hire Sutter
hey Ryan - at I'm a huge fan of the
videos never told my watch him makes my
day I don't know why did that accent he
said I Ryan Joe Connor
um you why'd you misspell your last name
it's not see why artsy or why you cry a
lot cuz you're a [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
it's my girlfriend calls me all the time
I'm sorry I didn't mean to take out my
personal aggression out on you Anthony
Rojas sometimes I rub myself in jelly
and pretend I'm a slug shout-out please
yeah I run myself in jelly too sometimes
not because I'm a slug it just helps
with lubrication for when you masturbate
the dick that that wasn't a phrase it's
not like Chuck the chain or something
the jelly thing good it's a good thing
you reminding me about that because
that's the tip I want to give all you
guys out there if I know we have a lot
of subscribers apparently who are like
thirteen-year-old kids meaning you just
started masturbating you guys so try the
jelly
Daniel Sottero I need a shout-out if I
don't get one they will kill my pet
t-rex save him Ryan
Daniel soltero your pet t-rex is a
douche it is destroyed many a city to
get back at you I [ __ ] your t-rex I
didn't want to do it it was really hard
getting an erection I had to take many
viagra pills it's amazing the power of
the mind has over viagra when you really
don't want you put your penis in
something but that's beside the point I
had sex with your t-rex hey there runs
that is my payback my revenge to you
Daniel soltero but Sottero sounds like a
possibly to be Italian so if you're
Italian good for you you probably have a
user dealing